その次の年には冬の百日間
その次の年に夏の百日間っていう
そういう修行スタイルをしたんですね
で 一日三回滝に打たれることっていうことで
それをやめたらもう自分で自害してくださいって言われるぐらい厳しく言われて
本当に始めた だから百日間はもう朝昼晩もう欠かすことなく
もちろん風邪も引くよ
寝ついてフラフラになっても滝に打たれなきゃ
だって約束だから その
私は修験道の先生に教えてもらったんだけど
その修験道の先生との約束だから
もうフラフラになりながらでもやりました
で 何 何がなったかって言ったら
まあちょっと難しいなっていうか
しょ まあほんとかっこつけていいの？それともほんと正直なところ
あの お任せします  かっこつけて言うと
滝に打たれる時に般若心経って我々唱えるんだけど
般若心経をね 二時間ぐらい唱えながら滝に打たれ続けるんだけど
その時に心が動かなくなった
過去に心がいかない 未来に心がいかないって
その状態 もうとにかく滝に打たれてる
今私は滝に打たれていますっていうところに心がしっかりと留められるようになったから
これこそが私は修行だと思ったの
仏法修行だと思ったの
それで でも滝行の欠点としては子供ができないっていうのと
体が弱いとができないでしょ
それからご高齢の方が絶対できないから
その三つの欠点があるっていうのを気づいて
それでそれが克服できる何かがあるんじゃないかと思ってスマナサーラ長老の元に伺ったのが始めなんです
この滝行のなんか子供でも
子供はできない また体が弱いとはできないという
この欠点を補える何か別の修行が教えていただけたらなと思って
だから修行の完璧な形としては
私は滝行と山岳修行 山の修行もずっとやって
三年間やってたんですけどね
山岳修行も大峯山奥掛け修行という修行も
案内人までできるところまでやり続けて
三年間かかりましたけどね
やり続けて その一歩一歩すごい丁寧に歩くんだわ
あの靴の靴底っていうかね
靴底がペラペラの下駄を履いて
足の裏の感覚にすごい集中しながら石を起こしたりしたら
修行仲間に落石がぶつかったりしたら大変なことになるから
もうあの浮石かどうかとかって
一歩一歩足の裏の感覚に集中しながら山岳修行でするので
だから修行 山の中ずっと歩き続けてる時
一歩一歩大切に歩いてたから
その時もう心が動かないっていうことが
自分はまあ午前中だけ
午前中だけじゃない 昼間
体力が残ってる間ぐらいしか歩けないんだけど
その間心が動きにくくなったというのがあったので
それだけど それも女性ができない
子供ができない ご年配ができないというその三つの欠点があったから
それらのことを補える何かを求めてスマナサーラ長老の元に伺った
そしたらさ その その日のうちにここは実況中継して歩きなさいって言われるわけよ
右足上げます 運みます
これでも真剣にやったらここが山の修行と同じなの
山の修行はさ 命懸けの滑落事故で何人も亡くなってるんだから
で 熊に叩かれて亡くなった人とかいるわけよ
たまったもんじゃない
だから だから私ホラ貝吹きながら歩いていて
まあまあほら あれなんで吹かったかって言ったら熊に襲われないためだったんですよ
あれ ホラ貝の音で熊ビビるんですよ
それもこの体見てもビビるでしょうけどね
この体に 体と その ほら
あのことダブルミックスで絶対熊には襲われないという自信があったから山修行ね
算段できたけど だからその山岳修行で徹底的にやってきたけど
実はここを右足上げる
運ぶ 下ろす 左足上げる
運ぶ 下ろすって真剣真面目にやるんだったら
山岳修行のあの真剣さと変わらねえなと思って
だから本当にスマナサーラ長老の修行を
私は滝行と山岳修行の最高の修行にちょっと取り入れたのかなっていう感じで伺ったんだけど
その気持ちはスマナサーラ長老とフヨウカ大姉さんのね
あのフヨウカ大姉さんがね
あの 私が あの 山岳修行と滝行こそが本物の修行と思ってるから
ちょっとスマナサーラ長老の教えを学びに来ただけですみたいな感じでいたら
フヨウカ大姉先生ね が
今までのことはとりあえず置いといてくれって言って
言ってくださって 私なんかめっちゃ若造よ
その頃 フヨウカ大姉先生がすごい年上の大先輩なのに
今までのことはとりあえず置いといてね
修行やってもらえませんかみたいな
すごい丁寧に言ってくださって
こんなことね さっき言われたから
ちょっと今までのことは置いとくかみたいな
置いてやってみたな スマナサーラ長老のその
ここが山岳修行やんって
なんだ だからそういう意味ではものすごく
まあ滝行も千回ぐらいやったしね
山岳修行も相当やった
結論として ここが我々の修行の道場になるんやと
どこでも道路でも山岳修行のできるんやと
例えば道歩いてて 危険なところ
車が往来多いところだったら
女性が内側歩いていただく
男性は外歩くとかね お年寄りの方は内側歩いていただく
男性の方は外歩くって
山道の修行と全く同じなの
山道も危険な方は 崖の方は強い男が立って待つ
で 安全な方をお年を召された方とか
若くてまだ筋肉しっかりしてない子が通るって
そういうふうに道もすごい分けてやるんだけど
道路歩いててもね そうやって歩けるし
気を配って歩くこともできるしね
そんなことをして修行しました
ありがとうございます
はい ありがとう  職業のことでは
よく言われます はいはいはい
はい お願いします じゃあ
先生ありがとうございました
今日の先生の説法 私はどっと来たんですけれども
こちらにも来ますので
あとで話します  いや すいません
先生の説法が私の胸にドンと来たのは
先生が平等だっていうのはいつもおっしゃるんだけど
今日のは私たちは生まれた時からもう平等で生まれてきてるんだっていうのがドンと来たわけですね
それでこちらに大乗仏教のお坊様たちには
今日先生が言われたこと
私は先生の遺言のような気がして
早口過ぎるでしょ ちょっと前のこと言いに来てくださいよ
遺言とか言われましたけど
今遺言とかおっしゃったんですけど
いや それじゃない 今まで聞いたぐらいちょうど
いや そういうことをおっしゃらない方がいいと思います
あの すいません それで会場の皆さんもそうなんだけども
私がもし子供とか孫にたちたちに平等だっていうことは
宗教とかそんなこと関係ないお話を今日してくださったわけですから
こちらの大乗仏教のお坊さんたちは
信者さんたちに最初にお話しされる時
平等なんだよっていう風に伝えてくださいますか？今日会場に
あの ね それをお聞きしたかったですね
だからみんなは後ろの方もそうだし
私も子供たちになんか喧嘩しても平等だよと一言言って
そこでもう終わってもいいような説法を私は今日はどんと来たんですね
だからぜひこちらのまあ漫才もいいんですけども
あの ごめんなさい 私が聞きたいのは
こちら本当にあの それこそ私たちが亡くなった時にはお世話になるお坊様たちですよね
そのお坊様たちがマツサカ先生が平等に生まれてきたんだっていうことを
こんなに力強くどんと教えてくださったわけですから
その そのとこから皆さんに説法していただけますか？っていうことをお尋ねしたかったんですね
ぜひ本当に だから漫才を聞いてると
あ 言ってもらい損ないなと思ったので
手が上がりました  司会で申し訳ないんですけど
漫才っていう風に受け取るのも主観です
そうですね ごめんなさい
じゃあやめますね じゃあ今日の平等っていうことは
宗派関係ない カトリックも何プロテスタントも関係なく
すいません 何度もすいません
教えっていうのは自分が自分の心に受けるものですから
人にどうこう言うことではないですね
だから何でも言っていいって
あなたがそういう風にいつも止めるのも私に対して失礼だと思いますので
私は本当にこちらの大乗仏教のお坊さんたちが平等であるということを伝えてもらえるかなと伝えてくださいとお願いしているだけです
はい ありがとうございます
よろしいですね 皆様平等ですからね
しっかりお伝えいただけますようにお願いいたします
私の方からもお願いしますということでね
大丈夫だと思います 紙についてね
ちょっと はい ありがとうございます
こちらがよろしい方の真ん中から後ろの方お願いします
すみません あの 先ほどあの聞き間違いかもしれないですけど
お釈迦様がもともとどんなことをおっしゃっていたかっていうことは
日本に明治になってから入ってきたってお話ありました
お釈迦様の直接の教え
はいはい その辺のことをちょっと詳しくお聞きしてもいいでしょうか
今アイコンタクト中ですのでしばらく
あのわかる範囲でよろしいですか？あのわからない
わからない 現実に言うと
これ仏教学っていうのは
例えば経典のどうやって伝わったとか
何時代に何が来たとか
正確じゃない部分もまだ研究されています
聖徳太子がそのこれを著したんじゃないんだとかですね
ですから若干違うことはありますが
基本的に中国からや朝鮮から仏典が来ているわけなんですね
ですから翻訳っていうことです
日本の仏教は幸い漢字をそのままこちらに来て
そしてその漢字を日本人が後に訓読みをしていくわけなんで
日本人がわかるように変換してるんですよ
中国人が理解するのとはまた違う読み方です
それも日本人がわかるように仏典を読み替えるわけですね
ってことは 日本人が受け入れやすいように仏教というのはやっぱり変わってきてるんです
で それがあるんですけれども
これはお釈迦様の教えだっていうのは間違いなくその当時から言われています
ただ その存在は伝わってないです
いわゆるパーリという
いわゆるパーリ語の仏典だったりとかっていうことが発見されたわけですね
逆に言うと 日本人にとっては
それで大谷探検隊のようにですね
海外に行けるようになった時に
初めてもう日本人が喜んで
お坊さんがですよ 喜んで
そのガンジー ガンジーじゃなくて
あのサンゾウと言うようにですね
冒険をしたという旅をして
で 明治の頃から仏典の研究が進んでいくんです
それ以前はやっぱり中国までだったんですよ
行けても だけど本物を求めて
弘法大師も伝教大師も中国に行ったということです
ですから お釈迦様を精神をということは
この日本の仏教においては紛れもなくその精神を受け継ごうとしていましたけれども
この仏典というのは ご存知のように
インドの方の後期からもうチベットだったりと
翻訳したものが基本的には中国に渡って
そしてこちらに来ているものなので
その直接ダイレクトに入るっていうことがなかったということは
これは事実だと思います
そういう点からすると
テーラワーダの各国と違って歩いて行ける距離とかですね
そういうふうなことから受け入れ
ただこの日本にこの仏教があるというのも奇跡みたいな感じではありますね
そういう受け入れられる土壌があったのと
それを仏教の本質がある意味変わっていくかもしれませんけど
伝わったという これは事実じゃないかと思います
はい いいですか？ もう一人後ろの方の方
もうこちらで最後になりますね
あの後ろの方 えーと すみません
よろしくお願いします
先ほどもこちらの女性の言われている題材になってしまって申し訳ないですけども
彼女が聞きたかったこととしてですね
仏教では一切皆苦を説いて
お釈迦様が説いていらっしゃるというのに
一方で永遠の幸せを求める
まあ涅槃のことを言ってるのかと思いますが
この矛盾を意味が彼女には理解できないので教えてほしいという質問なのですが
どのように理解すればよろしいでしょうか？とのことを大乗仏教の法様だけに一切回帰とニルバーナという永遠幸福
永遠の輪廻の苦から脱した完全なる自由なニルバーナ
まあそのでも一切皆苦
ここは知っているんですけども
あえて大乗仏教の法様に彼女はお答え
でも本当はスマナサーラ長老にお答え
ドゥッカ サンカルダ・ドゥッカとかニルマ・ドゥッカありますね
まあそのニルバーナの苦から一切の苦から解脱
まあ完全なるフリーになるんですけど
まあそれはちょっと置いておきまして
その質問に対してどのように大乗仏教の法様が
は お答えできないでしょう
できればその通りに一切帰くと涅槃という永遠の幸せ
でも二つの矛盾点は彼女には理解できないので教えてくださいという
そういうことです ですね
我々も体験してないからなぁ
でもスマナサーラだと依頼者がないんですよね
これは だから我々が何とかするしかないという最悪の事態に陥ってますね
だからあの まあ苦って言ったら生老病死があるでしょ
生きていくことっていうのは何が起こるかわからない
毎日ね 毎日不安で何が起こるかわからないって
その不安の気持ちが苦でしょ
それから年老いていくことも苦だしね
それからあの 生老病 病
病になることも苦だしね
そして死を迎えなければいけないことも苦だしね
それからオンゾエとかイヴェティティクとかあるでしょ
それも目 耳 鼻とかすべてのものにとった五感に
すべて五感 六感までだね
例えば目にも嫌なものが見える
耳にも嫌なことが聞こえる
鼻にも嫌な匂いがする
味も嫌な苦手な匂い 味を
あの 味わわなければいけないことがある
皮膚感覚も嫌なことがある
それから嫌なことを思い出してしまうことがあるでしょ
そういう嫌なことっていうのは
あのオンゾエ 嫌なことと会わなきゃいけない苦しみっていうのは
もう我々の六感すべてに攻撃してくるでしょ
それからアイヴェティティク
すごい大好きな風景とも別れなきゃいけないでしょ
大好きな言葉とも 言葉なんていうのは無常だから
瞬間でなくなっちゃうものだから
すぐなくなっちゃうでしょ
匂いも同じでね 大好きな匂い嗅いでたとしてもわからなくなっちゃう
味も同じで 大好きな味だとしても
ずっと食べ続けたらまた苦にいたるね
どんな美味しい 私も昔はあのくるくる寿司 50枚ぐらい食べれてたんだけどね
最近くるくる寿司も 20枚ぐらい食べたらもう苦に立っちゃうんだよね
それもおなかいっぱいです
そう いらんツッコミせんでいい
だからそうやってね 味わえるものも苦
苦に至ってしまうというね
まあそうやって考えると
もうとにもかくにも苦だらけでね
でもこの苦っていうのは
あの 我々生きてるのとセット販売なんだよね
生きてたら苦あるんだよ
だからもうこれは避けられない
永遠の幸せが待ってるわけじゃないんだよね
苦は避けられない だから苦はもうこれ諦めないとしかない
じゃあ 解脱 輪廻の道側にいては苦しみがもう終わりがない
ニルバーナ 涅槃に行けば
ニッバーナに行けば一切の苦しみが消えるんです
一是何であるのか それはその人の生命の連帯が
今度は大変でしょ ちょっと私もわかりかねるところがありますのでね
続きはあの二人でなんとか対決していただければなと
ありがたかった そういうわけで
スマナサーラたちはもうお帰りにならないと
大丈夫ですか？大丈夫
です もうちょっと伸ばせよという視線がここに見えましたので
何かありましたらお願いいたします
女性の方お願いします
修行について スリランカのお坊様方と大乗仏教のお坊様方にお伺いしたいんですけれども
瞑想をする時間の配分についてなんです
仏教圏に生きてますと
瞑想以外にも仏教圏だけじゃなく
お坊様方の学校でも 例えばスリランカの僧侶になる学校でもそうですし
日本の僧侶になるための学校でもそうなんですが
数学だとか英語だとか
いろいろな一般的な生きていく上で必要な学問を習得した上で瞑想修行にも励まれいらっしゃると思うんです
で ただ 自分の感想なんですけれども
一般的な学問ばかり勉強時間が増えてくると
なんか論理的な思考ばかりというか
思考でベタベタになってしまうような感覚が自分の中でありまして
ですので お坊様方はどういった時間配分というか
その一般的な学問を勉強する時間と瞑想修行に励まれる時間と時間の配分というのを考えて修行されていらっしゃるのかどうかっていうのを質問
今 ダンディーサラ長老にアイコンタクトを送ってます
[笑い]お互い拒否されてますので
ヤサさんということでね
[笑い]ヤサさんはお弟子さんだからね
一番弱い立場だから もうやれと言われてもはいって言わざるを得ないというかわいそうな状況なんですけど
じゃあちょっとヤサさん伺います
それ別なことかなって
ちょっと聞いて [笑い] いいのいいの
こういうこと  仏教の勉強と普通の一般的な学問というのは分けて勉強しますか？ 時間配分というか
その一般的な学問をスリランカとかでも僧侶になるための学校では
数学や英語とかそういうこと
一般的な勉強も含まれていると思うんですけど
その一般的な学問をあまりずっとやっていくと
逆に思考でベタベタになってしまう感覚が私の中ではあるんですけれども
その瞑想に充てられる時間がを長く取るだとか
そういう時間配分が学校で決まってたりするんですか？ その日本人である私に聞かれてもちょっと
スリランカの話ですもんね
スリランカの学校で勉強してて
一般的な勉強してて  僧侶になるための学校
スリランカの学校経験がないんですが
ちょっと私に振られてもちょっと
なんとかしろと  ただ 大丈夫です
別にスリランカにこだわったことではなくて
こう 思考がベタベタにならずに済むように瞑想修行に励むにあたって
時間配分 時間の使い方っていうのは何か
いい みんなのためになるようなことって何かアドバイスいただけるようなことありましたら
それはちょっと特別勉強している方に対して適切かどうかはわかりませんけども
このダンマパダ お釈迦様の死に言葉においては
もう全部なるべく少しでも善行為ができるのであれば
もう繰り返し再三再四できるだけ行うべきでありますというお話をされているわけですね
ですから その心を清らかにするということは
何をおいても優先順一位として
やっぱりやっていただくことが大切だと思いますし
ただ 一般的な我々っていうのは
お仕事であるとか 学校であるとか
もう選択の余地はありませんよね
ですから 選択の余地がない
そういう技術的なことっていうのは
やる必要は当然あるわけなんですけども
いわゆる隙間時間とかたくさんあるわけじゃないですか
我々には そういった隙間時間
並びに仕事終わった後にできるだけの隙間時間での慈悲の瞑想もできるわけじゃないですか
歩いている時 それから電話している時
様々慈しみを尽くす修行っていうのを充てられるわけですから
できるだけ なぜならば
我々はいつ死ぬかわからない
アッジェヤワ キッチャm アータッパン オージャンニャ マンナー スヴェという言葉
日日是好日教という日常仏教という教典あるんですけども
我々というのはいつ死ぬかわからないと
明日どのようになるかわかりません
そういう気持ち 心に置いておきますと
自分の背中を押してくれると思うんですね
善行為しなければいけないという
そういう気持ち 自分の生き方のモットーというんですかね
それを心に決めて生活していただいてれば外れることはないと思うんですね
ぜひお釈迦様の言葉を一つつ
自分の生き方のモットーにしていただいて
生活していただければありがたいと思います
ありがとうございます
我々大乗仏教はだいたいあの
だいたい学問を修めてから修行道場に入るという感じですね
で お釈迦様も修行道場の修行段階ですわ
で ともかく食べる時も一口一口実況中継しますからね
いまだに 笑ってもらう場所なんだけど
それでそこまで太ってるんですから
ちゃんとツッコミ入れてもらわないと
我々は修行道場ではバリバリ修行してね
もう一日中よ 修行道場出てからも一日中歩く時はいつも右足
左足 右足 左足 食べる時も運びます
噛みます 噛みます 運びます
そういう そういう生活を送っているのが我々大丈夫教ということが言えますよね
ありがとうございます
[拍手] ありがとうございました
木下さん そろそろ  そうね
終わりなんじゃないの
試合ちょっと長かったけど
すいません ありがとうございました
[拍手] 木下玲央師 どうしないか
アジャリ  ありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
それではプログラムの最後の締めと言いますか
締めくくりですね 祝福のご供養をお願いしたいと思います
少し準備の時間がいりますかね
少々お待ちください  今日は仏教を挙げて祝福
清水寺でございますから
皆様方は解散なさってもよろしいし
スタッフの方々は出ていったら困るしね
それからお席いっぱいありますからね
で まあ最後にあの こうする功徳をこうすることによって
お布施くださった方に感謝するという
我々伝統的な これは仏教
どんな仏教でもどんな宗教でもいいこと
えっと この会場費はね
このレンタルとね やっぱりいろいろ後ろもいろいろ部屋とか借りてるんだからね
で このそのお布施は米沢出様ですね
で 米沢出様のお布施で今日の会場が使うことにできました
心から感謝をいたします
仏法僧の御学がありますように
幸福になりますようにと誓願いたします
それから会場設 会場設
設 これは備品などの布施
どう読みます？会場  設営備品
など なお布施 まあいつでもいろんなことで協力していただけるんですけど
すごく頑張っていただいているんですね
石原幸恵様 あの幸恵様は今日だけじゃなくてね
ずっと協力してくれて
あのまあ当座 存分に楽しんでるんでしょ
石原さんがそれぐらいもう何でもやってくれるんだからね
誰も心配しないで全部任せちゃえば
二畳分ぐらいの力のある方なんです
で そのお布施で感謝いたします
石原武さんにも仏法僧の御報がありますように
心が清らかになりますようにと誓願いたします
えーと 二番目にあるのはこの総導
永世法名  これも今回は特別に殊勝な出来事でしたけど
カクタマと書いたマサヒロ様のお布施でございます
で マサヒロ様にもね あの
すごいずっと健康でありますようにと
あの 一人一人の健康のことを考えてね
お布施なさいましたので
ずっと健康でありますように
仏法僧のお守りが常にありますようにと
心が清らかになりますように
解脱に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
またあの 清水お墓の持ち主などはアンドサトミ様でございます
えーまあ その感謝いたします
まあ我々みんな助かったのはお弁当ですね
[笑い] で お弁当のお布施はヨコタネシュゲル様のお布施でございます
ですから みんなで一緒に感謝しなくちゃいけないんです
私も昼ご飯食べましたからね
で それから 正経寺から何かいつでも面白いことを毎年まあ作ってくれるし
絵はがきを作ってくれるできまして
ありがとうございます
今日もそういうあの 主にあの
こういう名前を挙げられるお布施のリストですけどもね
で 項目ごとに名前を挙げているだけで
他の方々ものお布施がありますよ
お布施っていうのはボランティアはお布施です
ボランティアはお布施です
形形でいろいろ手伝ってあげたり
いろいろアイディア出したりとかね
まあそういうことでね
あの 自分でお布施で成り立ったものでね
そういうボランティアとして
準備した方々 それからもう結構前からね
あの いろいろ計画立ててやらなくちゃいけないことで
そういう皆様方 また昨日もね
えーと ウェーサーカ祭典のA班やりましたからね
[笑い]まあそれもあの
狭い場所でやったからといって
それも大変な大きな業務でございましたし
まあそういう各あの 項目でさん-- 協力してくれた皆様に
あの ヴィパッサナーを通して
あの 祝福いたします お祈りいたします
それからせっかくあの
参加なさった方々も心から感謝いたします
まさか方々どうしますか
大丈夫 参加された方々も
あの ブッダのことを念じて思って清らかにここで参加になったので
皆様今日一日中 あの 孤独を背負う仕事をね
皆様の一日を あの 支えまったので
皆様にも仏法僧の あの
お守りがありますように
心が清らかになりますように
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
解脱に達することができますようにと心から
えーと お祈りいたします
で まあ教会の理事長の方々にはね
まあなんか特別にすると自分たちで自分たちを褒めるということになりますが
あの教会のサトウベスさん
えーと サトウアスコさんも
あの いろいろまあ結構苦労していろいろ準備してございまして
それからあの 理事長のお二人にも心から感謝をいたします
皆様の-- 皆様に仏法僧の御報がありますようにと最後に誓願いたします
サードゥ はい それではあの
締めくくってあげます最後
サードゥ [集唱][集
唱]サントゥッサコー ジャ スパロー ジャ アッパキッジョー ジャ サッラウ パブッティー サンティン リョ
ー チャニパコー ジャ アッパガッボー プレー スワヌキッポー マトゥプッダン サマチャレー キンチエーナ
ミンニュー パレー ユパワディーユン スキノーワ ケミノー ホントゥ サッベー サッター パワントゥ スキタッター
デーケー チパーナプー タッティー タサー ヴァッター パラー アナパシェサー ティーカワー エマンター ヴァマチマー
ラッサカーナ カトーラー ディッター
ワーデーワラッディッター
エジャトゥレー パサンティ アヴィトゥレー プーター エスティーラー サンベー サッター パワントゥ スキタ
ッター パロー パラン イプッベー タラナーティ マンニエタ カッタ チナンカン チー ギャーロー サナパティナ
サンキャー ナーンニャ マンニャッサ ドゥッカ ニッジェイヤ マーカヤタンニヤン プッタン パリサー エカプッタナム
ラッケー エワンティ サッバ ブーテースー マナサンター ワジェー アパリマーナン メッタンチャ サッバロー
カスミン マナサンター ワジェー アパリマーナン ブッダン アドーチャティーヤン チャラサンバーダン アヴェーラ
ン アサタッタン ティッタンチャラン ニシンノーバ サヤーノーワヤーワタッサ ヴィガタ ミットトー エタン サキ
ン アディッテーヤ ブラフマ メタン ヴィラーラン イダマボーディ キンチャ アヌパダンナ シーラワー ダッサネーナ
サンタン モッカーメー スーヴィネイヤ ヴェーダンナ ヒジャース サッバ セーヤン プナレーティー
ティー エテーナ サッチャワンジェーナ ソッティデー ワオトゥ サッバダー エテーナ サッチャワンジェーナ ワオトゥテー
チャティマンガラン エテーナ サッチャワンジェーナ サッバロー ブーディナッサトゥ トゥデータヤン チャックマ
エタラージャー アリッサワンノー パタウィッパバー ソタンタン ナマッサーミ アリッサワンナン パタ
ウィッパバー サンタヤッジャプッター ヴィハレー ムディヴァサン エーラーマナー レタブー サッバダン
メーデーメー ナモーデーチャナン パワヤントゥ ナマトゥ ブッダーナン ナマトゥ ボーティヤー ナモー ヴィム
ッターナン ナモー ヴィムッティヤー イマンソー パリッタン カッダー モーロー チャルティ ヘーサナー アペ
ータヤン チャックマ エタラージャー アリッサワンノー パタウィッパバー ソタンタン ナマッサーミ アリッサワンナン
パタウィッパバー サンタヤッジャプッター ヴィハレー ムラッティン エーラーマナー レタブー サッバダンメーデーメー ナモー
[仏教経典][経典]はい
皆様ありがとうございました
それでは あとは回向の文を皆様でお唱えして
今日の功徳を一切衆生に回向して終了ということなんですが
その前に一番最初になんか一言ございますので
あの 今日はあの 例年通りの例会に参加していただいている方はまあいらないでしょうね
一応この後ですね 祝福の糸とお水の授与というものがございますが
昨日すでに拝受いただいている方もいらっしゃるかと思います
その方はお水だけ先にお渡ししますので
係の誘導に従っていただければと思います
もうすでに準備が始まったって感じですけど
最後に皆様で香の文をお唱えして一旦締めたいと思います
画面の方をご覧いただけますでしょうか
ご唱和してください 香の文
あらゆる生命に憐れみをもって真理を説かれた恩師釈迦牟尼仏陀の聖なる教えに従い
我々がここまで積んだすべての功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 生きとし生けるものすべてが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サーリプッタ それでは繰り返しになりますが
この後ですね お坊様方より祝福の糸とお水の授与を行います
糸を結んで もうすでに昨日結んでいただいた方で希望されない方はですね
先にお水の方をお渡しいたしますので
係の誘導に従ってください
それから重ね重ね申し訳ないんですけど
席を立たれる際にですね
椅子の肘掛けと背もたれの消毒をお願いいたします
今日は仕事が多くて申し訳ありません
それからですね こちらから中野駅に向かって皆さんがお帰りになる時に結構混雑するということなので
中野駅をご利用の方は歩道の左側を
意識でご通行いただきますようにお願いいたします
中のほうかこちらへ来られる歩行者の方の妨げにならないようにですね
歩道の左側を意識して歩いていただければと思います
それではまずですね お水のみいただきたいという方から
お並びいただけますでしょうか
すいません まず前にお越しいただきまして
鐘を鳴らしていただきます
一番手前 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと念じながら鐘を鳴らしていただきます
次が初志初志貫徹という言葉はとても大切だって素晴らしいあると思います
鐘の後に その隣が幸こそサティこそサチ
サティこそ我々にとっての幸せだってことで
サティこそサチと願いながら花を置いていただいて
そんな流れになってますので
それが終わったら糸を結んでいただく方は糸を結んでいただいて
それから壇上に登っていただいて
お水だけの方はお水だけいただいて降りていただきます
よろしくお願いします
最後の言葉で舌を噛んで死にそうですけど大丈夫ですよ
そこでいいんだよ そこでいいんだよ
鳴らして上に登ってもらって
それではお水のみの希望の方
最初にお並びいただこうと思います
祝福の糸も一緒に結んでいただきたいという方は
もうしばらくお席の方でお待ちください
横じゃダメ 横だったらダメよ
横はへこんじゃうから
お水だけの方がいらっしゃったらこちらからお渡しします
どうぞお手に取ってお渡しいたします